welcome welcome everybody we are here
today to talk about lesson planning and
how at KH Academy and with con Migo we
can support you with lesson planning we
know we are all teachers we have been in
the classroom we have gone through
lesson planning we know how much time
and energy it takes on a daily and a
weekly basis to put together lesson
plans that aren't just done but that are
engaging and relevant to your content
and to your students so we're going to
show you today how kigo can meet you
right where you are are support you with
that lesson planning and making today um
more impactful to save you time so you
spend less time lesson planning and more
time teaching kids now in order to
access the features that we're going to
show you today you do have to have a
paid subscription to conmigo there's two
ways that you can do that the first is
through a district partnership the
second is just to sign up for a
subscription on your own now we are
going to drop a link into the Q&A here
in just a little bit normally it is $4 a
month just $4 a month to have access to
conmigo and to use this lesson planning
tool amongst many others but since y'all
are here with us today or watching this
recording we're going to give you a
coupon code get your pencil out we're
going to drop it down that coupon code
is just lesson plan and the number one
lesson plan number one all one word if
you will and that's going to give you
the ability to try conmigo for just a
dollar for the first month so again to
access these features it is paid but a
bargain for the time you're going to
you're going to save so with that I'm
going to hand it over to my co-presenter
today gentes it's all yours thanks sty
hi everyone really excited to have all
of you here to learn a little bit more
about KH academy kigo and of course
lesson plans so I'm G buunis I'm a
senior product manager on our teacher
experience team and over the last couple
months we've been hard at work to turn
kigo into to a useful teaching assistant
and of course a good lesson plan writer
what we've learned is that out of the
box AI is pretty okay at creating a
lesson plan but it's only okay and that
creating a lesson plan that is truly
useful that we ourselves as a lot of us
are former Educators myself I used to be
a middle school English teacher would
actually use in our classrooms and so
our first attempts using kigo uh was
okay we actually started evaluating kigo
using the rubrics we ourselves would
have evaluated uh first year teachers we
ourselves were evaluated using these
rubrics and we evaluated kigo and sorry
to kigo it initially scored as
unacceptable to developing it it didn't
always have lesson plans that um didn't
par or used to parent the standard waros
that didn't always cover the
prerequisite skills parts of our prompt
that we so carefully informed cono to be
pedagogically appropriate standards
aligned they are being IGN igned uh so
we of course set to work and so we found
by giving cono access to our KH Academy
content by breaking the prompt into
careful sections the way we would as
Educators going step by step with direct
instruction guided instruction warm-ups
exit tickets we were able to get kigo to
be much much better and we're happy to
say that at the current moment kigo is
somewhere between developing and
proficient and of course we are somewhat
perfectionist here so going to continue
working and trying to get kigo to be uh
beyond that and truly truly exceptional
but ultimately what this comes down to
is we believe kigo is best with educator
input that we need the educator in the
loop to make kigo the best it can
possibly be so you'll see uh the things
that Stacy shows today we've designed
kigo to not just create a lesson BL but
to really co-create a lesson plan with
you to take your input to bring uh you
know its expertise to create create that
initial lesson plan but then to work
with you together to make that lesson
plan really fit the needs of your
students your classrooms um and your
schools so really excited uh to have you
all put this tool through its Paces I
will be on board here to answer any
questions in the Q&A um but without
further Ado I will happily pass it over
to Stacy to show you all lesson planning
with
cono all right y'all let's dive in so
I'm going to go ahead and share my
screen and we are going to go into the
lesson planning experience so I have
opened up here to our AI activities page
what you see on the lefthand screen if
you're not familiar with conmigo are a
whole bunch of activities that are super
useful for creating lesson plans for
engaging your students and we are going
to zoom in on this create a lesson plan
feature so I'm going to go ahead and
open that
up and it's asking me what content I'm
going going to be teaching so the first
thing to know is that this experience is
going to be tailored to the region that
you have selected so for today I'm
working on California but up here in my
settings if I am in a different area I
can just select Florida or Indiana or
any other state that I'm working from so
that's right there and super easy to
change and what that's going to do is
allow you to have a lesson plan that's
tailored to your state standards and
reflective the content that you're
required to teach so I am going to let
kigo know that I am going to be teaching
Algebra 1 and we're working on rate
conversion so I was a middle and high
school math teacher for a while I'm
going to lean into my old content but
don't worry I'm going to show you some
other content areas in just a bit so
it's working on some ideas for me giving
me a couple of things that might reflect
what I'm teaching with my students so
right now again because because I am
working on California standards it's
giving me those lessons and those
standards right there and as it turns
out there's rate conversion so I'm going
to click into
that and we're going to open up a lesson
plan here and notice that it starts
writing the lesson plan right away it's
going to draft a complete lesson plan
that has all the necessary components so
you're seeing standards objectives all
sorts of things that are ready to go now
let's imagine we're on a cooking show
and we're watching The Baker bake right
here I'm going to flip over to the part
where we pull the finished product out
of the oven and we see a complete lesson
plan here so notice we have the
objectives lesson activities including a
warmup we have what we might use for
direct instruction guided
practice also important independent
practice and an exit ticket teacher
resources and how how we might
differentiate instruction that was
always the thing that took me the
longest to plan for in the classroom how
am I going to reach Advanced Learners
how am I going to reach Learners that
need a little extra boost that need to
strive for a few more steps and
supports notice that our vocabulary is
in here even some possible extensions
and way that we ways that we might
extend the learning and take it just a
little bit further we have required
materials a summary and even account of
how we might spend our time and our
minutes so with that it's given me a
lesson plan this looks great but I need
to make a few adjustments to reflect our
content so I'm going to go back up here
to the top forgive me while I scroll and
on my campus we are actually required to
write objectives as as I can statements
so what I'm going to do is highlight
this objective I'm G to tell kigo I want
to chat about this now notice I can chat
about this or I can just ask kigo to
replace this with something new I'll
show you that in just a minute but for
now I'm going to chat about this
objective so it's going to tell me
something about this objective let me
know what I'm working on and then I'm
just going to tell kigo can you rewrite
this as an I
can
statement and notice that it did exactly
that it came back in and now I can
transform rates between different units
and apply these conversions to solve
real world problems so it did exactly
what I asked it to do I'm also going to
go down to let's see my direct
instruction section here and I know that
I need to work out of a specific page in
my textbook so I'm actually just going
to add another step we are going to open
our textbook to page 19 which is from
chapter 4 lesson 6
so notice that I can type directly into
to the lesson plan and make adjustments
and I can even remove things so if this
section right here this question is not
something that I want just going to
delete that and remove it from my plan
I'm going to go down here as I've read
this you know taking the time to really
read each of these questions I'm going
to scroll down to the exit ticket and
again I think my students might be a
little disengaged by this time a lot of
times at the end of a math lesson
students aren't with me anymore so I'm
going to tell kigo that I want to about
this
and I would like
oops got a lot to say about this and
certainly I can sit and read this this
is going to give me a really clear
explanation as to why this exit ticket
is written this way and different things
that I might do to gauge interest but
I'm going to ask kigo to
rewrite this exit ticket so that it
relates to something that my students
are interested in and right
now that is I'm G to go with Taylor
Swift We want to write rewrite the exit
ticket so it has something to do with
Taylor Swift and notice that it is doing
that so no matter what your students are
interested in I've seen teachers do this
with fortnite video games different
animals different activities that
students are interested in I can ask
kigo to make those adjustments and this
is certainly something that you could do
on your own this is something that you
can come up with these ideas but that
takes time right it takes maybe some
Google searching sitting around pulling
things out of the back cobweb part of
our brain and now we can get kigo to do
that in a fraction of the time in just a
few seconds to establish relevance for
our students and to just bring them in
right my kids see Taylor Swift on the
page or fortnite or horses whatever it
is they're interested in it pequs their
interest and they're with me just a
little bit
longer another thing that I can do if I
don't like this activity I can highlight
that and maybe I don't want to chat
about it but I just want kigo to replace
it with something
new and it's going to do that just give
me another idea right I didn't like
what's there I want to see something new
so no this lesson plan is completely
customizable and Genta shared about this
earlier this is what I love about it
it's not giving me a packaged thing that
I have to take as is I can make this my
own I can add I can delete I can make it
so that it's relevant and engaging for
my students and when I'm all done I can
either print it exactly as it is or I
can export this lesson plan into word to
make those adjustments and then print it
out so super exciting to have all of
those options and the objective is to
give you time back we all have to lesson
plan but if you don't have to spend so
much time doing it you have more time to
focus on Learners on teaching and maybe
even more time with your family more
less time that you're sitting at school
working on these things at the end of
the day so for new teachers maybe this
gives you some fresh ideas maybe it
helps you support through those what are
all the pieces what am I supposed to
have for a long time teachers if you've
been at this for a while I know that
after I've been in the classroom for
several years I got really stuck in
doing the same things year after year so
what I love about this as a veteran
teacher is that it gives me new and
fresh ideas things that I can pull in
and what I just showed you my kids love
Taylor Swift make this math lesson about
Taylor Swift that changes instruction
and engages brings life to my classroom
in a way that I just really haven't seen
before I'm going to double back to
making sure that you
noticed these lesson plans are based on
the standards for your state and at the
very beginning of this I showed you that
you can even go in and change your state
you can make sure that you're set to the
state standards that are relevant to you
so that it's fully customized and
relates to the content because kigo is
here to support you with tailoring the
plan to the interests of your
kids so with that I showed you how to
get here from the AI activities page
remember we were in here we went into
that create a lesson plan there's a lot
more that we can do I click up here into
our courses menu notice that we have
courses in math in science humanities
financial literacy even some courses in
reading and language arts but if I
scroll down here I want to draw your
attention to our digital sat course I'm
going to go in here we know we have a
lot of students that are preparing for
this change in the
SAT we have a course in MA in digital
sat math and reading and writing when I
open up this reading and writing course
maybe I'm a Home Room teacher an
advisory teacher I'm working with
students to prepare for the digital sat
and it may content that I teach on a
regular basis or it may be content that
I'm not accustomed to teaching a lot of
times that happens for advisory teachers
and Home Room teachers and what I want
you to notice is that when I go in here
and I open up this
course if I go into any piece of content
and I open up that co-editor experience
I clicked on conmigo down there in the
corner if you didn't see that I'm just
opening up kigo my little co- teer there
on the side and I'm going to click on
help me write a lesson plan and notice
we have that exact same experience
populate exact same behavior so I did it
in math now I can do it in digital
sat I might even choose to go
into a science course so I'm going to go
into High School
physics into any one of these let's
check out work and energy that's what my
class is doing right now we're looking
at some work example problems I can open
up con Migo help me write a lesson plan
and that same customizable
standards-based lesson plan is going to
pop up and be right there ready for you
I'm super excited about this feature
across content no matter what I'm
teaching it's customizable it's there
and it's relevant to kids we know that
what you are doing makes a difference in
the learning process and it in making
that connection with students that
that's what drives learning outcomes
it's not just about standing up there
and teaching right so when we can
connect with what matters to kids with
what's important to kids we're going to
make learning happen so our goal is to
give you time back more time to focus on
teaching more time in your
day so with that I'm I hope you're
feeling as excited as I am um again take
a look at these courses it doesn't
matter what you're teaching science you
got a co-editor mathematics economics
doesn't matter what it is you can have
support planning your lessons you can
have that time back in the day so we are
so excited that this valuable feature is
available to you again with that
subscription remember that coupon code
that I shared with you earlier it's just
lesson plan and the number one one word
all switched together lesson plan one
and when you enter that code you can get
con Migo for just a dollar for the first
month otherwise it's just $4 a month
that's worth it in my mind to save this
time and not have to worry about sitting
there for hours writing lesson plans
every week so I hope that you are as
excited as we are and uh we hope you
have a wonderful afternoon thank you so
much for joining us
today